we have a voicemail that number is two
one nine two david p here is a voicemail
about the outright and about so-called
sjw's take it listen to this hey David
Kurt from Alabama here I'm just
wondering about your opinion on why
isn't the right the outright
libertarians in general are so obsessed
with the social justice warriors and
whatnot yeah so you could just let me
know I'd be awesome thank you yeah this
lends itself to a sort of longer answer
but the short answer as to why the
alt-right is obsessed with criticizing
social justice warriors is that they're
an easy target right so the so-called
social justice warriors that the
alt-right likes to criticize make up a
tiny tiny fraction of the left and they
are low-hanging fruit and by criticizing
them you're caricaturing a minority
element of the left without actually
having to deal with the very very
significant shortcomings of alt-right
ideology to the to the extent that it is
in ideology and you can avoid having to
actually talk about real issues and
solve some of the difficult problems
that we have going on just criticize
sjw's or some trigger warning or
something like that and you know I
criticize that stuff too but I criticize
it in proportion to how much of a
problem it is and don't blow it up but
it's just it's just an easy target for
the alt-right that's what it is yeah
it's very easy to debate someone who
doesn't believe in free speech or you
know you can tell there they're clear
contradictions with well they talk about
racism and these other issues but it is
just a small segment on the left and I
think they would rather debate against
those people then talk about taxes of
course and healthcare and all that other
stuff no question about it and that's
why they're doing it and it's become
very profitable actually online you can
make a lot of money just criticizing
social justice warriors and pretending
that they're sort of the a microcosm of
the left when in fact they're kind of
the exception to the left and most
guesses it would be interesting to see
if that contingency starts to grow more
or fades away over time yeah the
contingent yeah that's a good question
I think that
they are eventually going to fade away
that's my view on it we've got a great
bonus show for you today david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show don't miss the
bonus show it's a good one today